bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono opachi j
poi ci siamo sul course of the year text
ragazzi è un nostro si pronuncia così ma
non importa nel caso ho fatto un film di
merda quindi non rinfacciate melo
vabbè uno script tutorial non ne frega
un cazzo perfetto siamo partiti così ma
dai
[Musica]
ma ci siamo arrivati praticamente era
come va bene a [ __ ] che ne so io era
il tutorial questa ragazzi era il
tutorial io ho fatto skip to tò riall è
praticamente quella da una parte di
allenamento perfetto siamo partiti
adesso raga che ne so io
vabbè potevo risparmiarmela poi penso
che chi se ne fotte dove dobbiamo andare
là che non lo so
andiamo avanti c'è un teschio bellissimo
è bello che il dott
e cosa me ne faccio che ne so che schifo
questa roba non lo voglio sapere andiamo
avanti
e diventato c'è una cosa e poi gli ho
preso qualcosa che non so che cosa va
bene andiamo avanti così e bullismo però
tra l'altro ragazzi spero che vediate sì
penso di sì mi era solo buongiorno massa
altre chicche la messa qui senta non ha
una bella c'era lei è una bruttissima
personale consiglierei di mangiare un po
di più va beh comunque io vado a anche
amici quindi se in compagnia ma dillo
che ne so a voi mi fate la chiacchierata
notturna che bello mi fa piacere che hai
trovato
che cazzo di trappole che non le vedo
mai
va beh ma tanto non c'è la vita raiola
che me ne fotte accendiamo questa è
un'altra porta si apre tutto che culo
kiwi oslo you down lui ti rallenterà chi
è che mi rallenterà topo gigio
non c'è nessuno ci sono dei soldi vai
prendi i soldi al rafano haga che cosa
cazzo dei soldi io ho tanto li prendo
chi è stato c'è mica qualcuno qui sotto
ho sentito qualcuno che ha fatto non so
chi sarà va beh io io prese cos'è sta
roba
ma che è sta merda che ogni tanto trova
a terra va bè non importa andiamo avanti
ragazzi ma perché mi consigliate
starebbe bongiorno
ti faccio un po di luce perché di sicuro
6 al buio non è che ti diverti e va bene
mi lascia un po di luce a te mi dispiace
ma non c'è la torcia quindi tarrant
attacca piano pezzo va beh cosa c'è
addio chi è questo ragaglia tutto c'era
qualcuno che ho visto non sono pazzo
cos'era mio dio peccato tu porca [ __ ]
[ __ ] correnti da dove apparso ma che ne
sai
ma [ __ ] dei tutorial ripartiamo
dicevi voi se mi devo prendere colpite
c'è un'altra viste cosa che non so che
servono
vabbè praticamente ma queste sono babbo
c'era c'era un demo attivarli si cose
che mi servono che ne so dai ma perché
devo perdere del tempo gira questa merda
a cosa mi serve o le guardate che pochi
che cazzo era porca [ __ ] sei stato tu
stronzo
ho chiesto addio raga sto trappola mi sa
che non è che mi ferisce soltanto
aspettate la devo passare calmi calmi
calmi ok bene ciclo dei a vedermi morire
bastarda tanto non son morto dove devo
andare di qua ragazzi devo andare cos'è
ma ciò una ciotola cioè che cazzo era
solo umore non lo so senti volevo dire a
voi una ciotola no perché l'ho presa io
mi spiace montanari doc stronzo di merda
che vuoi vedermi morire in un film
spiace ma non è o non oggi i numeri oggi
ragazzi scontino a fare così però prima
o poi io lancio il monitor perché non
meno me ne accorgo che ci sono ma si può
spegnere la torcia volendo perché per
l'affare mi vede sebbene madonna
santissima se ancora una volta spruzzano
sti cosi ci sono dei soldi all i video
grazie ragazzi non so cosa sto facendo
c'è un buco chi cazzo ha scavato staico
c'è un buco va bene ti chiamo c nel buco
sta roba che sa che cosa mi serve a un
buco così spiegatemelo a magari a
scappare a quella fare se per caso mi
rincorre a me non c'avevo pensato va
bene ma bella bella idea
oddio cos'è
salve lei è meno fortunato degli altri
vedo dove devo andare di qua race una
porta perfetto vai entriamo nei meandri
di darmi o dove cazzo siamo
raga aiuta non avevo visto dove può
arrivare il campo di coordinamento e
parte corradi dove dove non lo so entra
qui sotto che non può passare vice oca
dove è indietro
ce l'abbiamo fatta penso ma è meglio
correre di qua non ce l'ho già passato
no va bene corri corri a [ __ ] le
trappole vorrebbe sì se corro più le
trappole sono incasinatissimo allora
ragazzi
non so dove però non lo so aiuto dove
aiutami tu fa qualcosa
raga mi sa che devo tornare indietro
perché concetto che cazzo ci stai a fare
tu se non mi viene anche una mano raia
aiuto cosa devo fare quindi torna negli
torniamo indietro va bene torniamo
indietro ragazzi cè un affare enorme che
non so che cos'è do o bio bio accordi di
qua corri di qua dove che parta accende
agenti non so dove sto andando a gli 866
ficcati p dentro me ne frega niente di
che cosa più di chiesto cosa che non mi
trovi conte grosso quell'affare ma che
cazzo merda non mi ha visto sì mi ha
visto a yacht a vela fare man mano se
passa vicino alla trappola rumore verona
ecobio cosa enorme
lisa mi sa che la trappola non gli fa
niente su certo presentimento devo
magari mentre va verso i cosi dominio
dai colpa mia allora ci risiamo però
stavolta è sempre e sempre diverso la
zona in generale perché non è mai uguale
quanti ti do fuoco stronzo ti do fuoco
te lo meriti va bene non so che cosa ci
sto a fare ma vabbè passiamo e c'è
qualcuno da joe vero c'è qualcuno già no
non lo so io sento un ruggito continuo
ma non so da dove arriva cos'è raga
cos'è il tipo codato fuoco prima allora
no vabbè non importa che continui a
bruciare di qua non so che cosa c'è
boni andiamo di qua perché l'unica
strada che ancora non ho preso che curi
capitano preso una freccia in pieno cosa
c'è di qua non lo so merda e da qualche
parte iota aiuta entra qui dentro
accadono cosa c'è di qualche non
previsto non lo so
giornata alcol dei portici sono ragazzi
io io non lo so quante porte ci sono ma
entro in cui dio e veloce le nozze
proprio dio che puro assurdo che culo
assurdo cioè mi sono salvato in una
maniera il preside ma guardi non è non
entri dentro e non entri che è brutta la
situazione di là va bene
no no no no ok se ne fa bastardo v'è
dove io io io non posso muovermi di
carne giusto dove possibile ragazzi
vabbè io devo fare uno scatto
incredibile tipo perché non so dove
maledizione bastardo no no
apri apri apri palazzo monte [ __ ] non
eccesso non ha un senso sto gioco nè
possibile ti circondano stimino tauri
delle palle non sono dodici volte che
iniziano dove sei brew dove sei fammi
capire dove sei
allora il primo è lo scopo ragazzi
arrivare da una porta all'altra senza
farsi in più mare da sti cosi che non so
dove sono spero non sia di qua perché
sennò ce l'ho nel capra anzi benissimo
credo di averlo forse laggiù ragazzino
non mi ha visto devo averlo tirato io
non aggiungo niente perché so già che
andiamo in piazza madonna santissima
quanti così ci sono così che mi danno un
nervoso io devo andare di qua raga
l'unico l'unica zona
devo arrivare alle porte prima che mi
prendano quei cosi ma è difficilissimo
c'è un'altra roba lì sotto i soldi me ne
fotto ma sa che tedesco di qua vivo non
me ne frega niente
dove sto andando c'è una porta da
qualche parte no veloci bisogna che ci
prenda dov'è quella fare non lo so
[ __ ] [ __ ] corri corri da
qualche parte cordi non so dove dico a
destra su tutto uguale non lo aiuta
proteggimi tuo amico porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
che da quando di nuovi anche tu
non ha senso questo gioco di merda non
ha senso allora ragazzi io ci sto
lentamente perdendo le speranze brutto
bastardo
da quando ti muovi da quando
vabbè allora questo è l'ultimo tentativo
lo faccio bene però lo faccio bene
stavolta non muoio
le ultime parole famose poi mi arriva
una freccia in faccia da qualcuno e
muoio è praticamente che era strumolo va
beh sei tu che è scoraggiato di la
verità che ce n'è un altro giorno
l'avevo visto vabbè è praticamente
dischi cosi raga su un milione ce n'è
uno che si muove e non so che stai fermo
stai fermo
adesso gioca a vedere sti cose perché
uno dove dove dovete dovere recarmi non
devo non devo morire non devo morire non
devo morire non devo morire carrè
carlino devo morire di qua brutti
stronzi non mi muovete dove andrebbe che
parte non so dove non è la propria parte
non so dove
ok calmi calicanto cantoni a rischio la
mia vita e forò bikers che fa la porta
la porta brutto bastardo stai fermo che
apriamo veloce cosa ti guardi va bene
sto facendo tantissimi ce la sto facendo
è una cosa impressionante processo sto
facendo da ferioli non incontra nessuno
faccia una fine suo gioco devi andremo
avanti finché non riesce a raggiungere
alla fine
ok
direi che è meglio passare di qua perché
di lai c'è una brutta persona benissimo
di qualità di co qua sotto questo tocco
sotto sotto ok ok
quando mi pare giusta i fermo qua non mi
può raggiungere quasi sicuro penso poi
in un noto severo la cosa è l'unica cosa
che è buona è che quando si avvicina la
torcia diventa blu quindi c'è te ne
accorgi in poche parole quindi come sono
tra accorgersi abbastanza dato che un
colosso di quello ci siamo fra madonna
lorìa girato di brutto ognuno va dove
c'è stata mai mai mai mai già stiamo
facendo raga è il tentativo buono questo
prestabili c'è la mappa ma va ma che
cazzo ne sapevo io ma di queste cose
perché è perché non mettete i tutorial
che qualcuno segue
vabbè raga e non posso dire niente su
sto fatto perché sono io che non ho
seguito il tutorial e va bene ok se c'è
la mappa è molto più facile di prima
perché almeno so dove sto andando
vabbè andiamo di madonna sabati causa di
colpi in fan prenderesti cosi devo mica
se questa roba mi cadde addosso son
cazzi perfetto calmi stai fermo non
tardar bene tanto quella strada chiusa
quindi non ci passo vicino dove dove sto
andando per beni vedete che la mappa
serve perché non so dove sto andando
vini va bene allora di qua
no no no no no no no no no no no ok
prima non ce n'era neanche uno adesso
subito bene alla ragazzi dobbiamo
scappare via dico abbia dico
assolutamente via cos'è quarti ce ne
sono
cos'era
ragazzi io è un vicolo cieco non so dove
sto andando
vai di qua veloce veloce che ce la porta
veloce veloce vero quante sono le porte
2 entra veloce velocissimo e dolcissimo
e questa non è a portal i primi dove
sono in un testo posto cos'è dove siamo
e siamo finiti cos'è buongiorno detto
non vorrei fumato a quanti soldi vi
voglio tutti
rivoglio prendo tutto quanto mi dispiace
ma è mia
doveva solo stare sveglio chi dorme non
piglia fa vj al ragazzino scettro e mio
grazie mollano
sì però non ti cazzare stai molto calmo
che grazie mille l'ho preso lo stesso
sia che diventa era dietro non me n'ero
accorto va beh prendiamo quello che
rimane tanto va bene facciamo finta di
niente o uno scettro serve qualcosa non
lo so
potevo andare devo tornare indietro non
c'è più la mappa non si apre qui
venissimo aver appreso uno debba tornare
indietro ma che me ne faccio di uno
scettro
non lo so e tipo una roba magica possa
uccidere i minotauri questi socialista
rocco noi torniamo indietro ragazzo o
uno scettro brutto stronzo uno scettro
non mi serve un cazzo però di qua ci
siamo arrivati a [ __ ] dove ok raga lo
scettro sono soltanto forti arrivare sta
roba
ok era meglio sono lo prendevo mannaggia
a me che l'ho preso porca [ __ ]
volevo io uno scettro servirà a qualcosa
sta merda tradizione
io ci provo magari si avvicina tipo di
carta il gelo scettro sono sempre io a
dire di concludere qui perché non ha
senso che continua a prendermi parti
questo è fatto veramente bene come gioco
comunque veramente è stata un'esperienza
orribile e vabbè dai ragazze viso è
piaciuto al santo commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete a cristicchi mettere invece
vediamo non prossimo video belle ragazze